i remember picking them up in columbus
that's where we signed the contract i
can't remember if i'm driving
or if i'm in the back
i'm counting the money
like 10 racks right there
yeah it was all hundreds people start
thinking about 500 a month i'm a
freshman i'm gonna have this for three
years
[Music]
so who we got in the pool hall today we
got a hall of famer my man chris carter
what's up baby how are you living right
how you doing man i said a lot of things
let's see how nice you are at pooh my
hands is nice they just ain't nice it
poop
come on
man oh come on get in there solid break
solid break so when'd you start playing
football i started playing football at
eight years old i tried to play when i
was seven me and my cousin went down to
the park he was like man i'll dock up
the birth certificate
to make you born a year earlier i was
trying to play when i was seven and the
lady was like i think you need to bring
your mom back i was like okay i'll go
home and get her a year later we didn't
come back too
so yeah that's my first experience
football was eight years old first time
i touched the ball in the game scored a
touchdown at that point it was just it
was history okay so young kid middletown
ohio what gravitates to football i love
the contact man i grew up a better
basketball player in high school until i
turned 16-17 than my recruitment i was
all-american in both but i was
first-team all-american in football so
in the process of trying to decide where
i was going to go to school i was only
going to be recruited by schools that
could let me play both so
that's one reason why i chose ohio state
okay i'm so glad man we didn't play for
any money
okay
you get to ohio state what was that
experience like and what was going on
in the background that beginning was
just not real good and talking to my my
buddies they were talking about quitting
going back home and i was like man i
can't go back to the crib like i can't
go why why was that not an option when
you grew up in a small town man
regardless how good you are there are
people that are always trying to hold
you back or say things you ain't gonna
never make it you ain't gonna be nothing
but
man you get those voices man everyone
gets them for sure what was it like for
you within the 80s dealing with these
ramifications and these different
stipulations of a different time well it
was totally against the rules any type
of benefit for any type of student
athlete so you didn't have the ability
to work you also didn't have the ability
to be able to take any type of
endorsements or anything like that it
was totally different
i said today's quotes
you couldn't take anything but
was there things still going on
absolutely yeah i made up my mind i
really wanted it made the commitment to
them i wasn't going to play basketball
and then the next month the coach called
me into his office and said i gotta tell
you something i was like what is it he
said you've been one of the few freshmen
in the history of the playboy
all-american that they're naming you to
next year's playboy all-american team
i was like really and he was like yeah i
that's like what does it require he said
well they have a big photo shoot it's
going to be in miami we're going to send
someone down there with you oh yeah
first trip to miami this is before your
day but man miami vice was hot
all right crockett tubs
and then they told us we were staying at
the hotel where they were doing a lot of
the filming and everything wow oh my
goodness so we go to the photo shoot and
then some of the older guys they're
going to take me under the wing they
introduce me to a guy saying i want to
introduce you to my guy that happened to
be lloyd bloom of the legendary lloyd
and norby walters
they were kind of booking agents
in the music industry and they had
10 of the top 15 black artists in r b
and they were trying to make a mark in
sports wow it was like wow this could be
good it was talking about marketing the
players with the bands going to see all
these acts and i was like if i could
just go to all these concerts i'm going
to be cool if i don't do nothing else
and i really thought
at that time i was doing something
cutting edge ahead of like i knew this
was a decision i was going to have three
years from now but if i could take care
of this now and the benefit of that i
think they gave me 15 000. 15 your eggs
yeah i remember picking them up in
columbus that's where we signed the
contract and like that next week i can't
remember if i'm driving
or if i'm in the back
i'm counting the money
[Music]
it was all hundreds it was all hundreds
i think i got 10 to sign five later on
and then also i got a car and then i got
500 a month at the western union you
know people start thinking about 500 a
month
i'm a freshman i'm gonna have this for
three years wow so
i didn't have to worry about
all that immediately they gave me an
application for an american express i
was like i ain't never had a credit card
i ain't even never lived in a house and
i always lived in a housing project
that's a good conversation you're good
oh we just getting started bro
you sure you ain't playing before
i didn't say i didn't play before i just
said i'm not that good at it that was
sweet that was nice if the nil rules
existed today when you were playing in
college how much money do you think you
would have made
it's not a how much trouble you think
i'm gonna get into so what did money do
for you then the things i was doing just
allowed me to do more of it and we were
just smoking weed just a little bit and
that's just when cocaine people started
smoking it
rocking it up and people had just
started putting it in marijuana
and a guy at a party man had put one in
the cigarette and man when he did that
like
like he shot a shot off with him in my
head and it was like i had never
experienced anything like that in the
morning you know it was or nah that was
my first time ever
experiencing crack cocaine
and it blew my mind unfortunately
that started when i was at ohio state
all the money and everything that came
with that miami trip
put you in that situation how were you
responding to that
over the following years after that this
is the thing i don't know how i played
at such a high
high high level my sophomore year i went
on to break all the sophomore records
my junior year i went on to break all
the junior records every bowl game i
played in i was mvp in that bowl game
and i don't say that from a bragging
standpoint it's just i don't know how i
was able to function at that level i was
always on time never had any
disciplinary stuff but ultimately it's
going to catch up to you
yeah to me it's not about the money i do
believe that there is a way that we can
compensate but giving young people
unlimited amounts of income is not the
best thing i'm not happy for the guys
because guys eventually going to get
their money i'm more happy for the women
and they're able to take advantage of it
tick tock all these things sell them
like yes they can do it the right way
what's the advice you give them right
now in terms of how to navigate the
space now being able to monetize up to
likeness i would say that there's really
no experts in this area and be very
careful the universities can recommend
to the athlete a business or something
that they can go to but people don't
make mistakes this is new territory
people are going to make mistakes but
us thinking that young people are going
to be
better off with money than without it
that would be interesting to watch you
speak on the first hand yeah yeah gator
so what you got you got a couple balls
over here tied up i'm waiting for you to
break them up down there for me yeah
why would i do that
now chris carter scored 1600 points in
high school
we're gonna see how nice you still are
right now in basketball how's that sound
let's check it out let's get the pop-up
shot going real quick all right i'm
gonna start these questions here in
three two one who was the hardest db to
play against dion sanders best city to
visit on road green bay
favorite route to run ah i'm nice
post corner
yeah number 80 or number 88 80. who are
you listening to before a game
tupac all right hall of fame ring
or super bowl come on stop playing hall
of fame
funniest teammate you've ever had john
randall slot or whiteout
[Music]
brady or roger brady man stop already
what qb do you wish you could have had
play with dan marino
dirtiest opponent you ever faced
andre waters 10 seconds
bill romanowski
what current wide receiver blows in hall
of fame deandre hawkins
last one best fans in the nfl
anytime you go on the east coast they
gonna give it to you east coast fans
what's that rough let's see new york so
new york city got the best fans roughest
roughest roughest place to play yes
chris
appreciate you coming by the pool you
got a great show bro hey thank you very
much man appreciate y'all for watching